and he'll face jake arrieta who made one
start john
and it's the first time this year the
phillies have kind of gone through a
rotation where
a starter actually started earlier in
the same week
over the third segura has it spin off
his glove quickly throws to first
in time to get swanson he signals
immediately to brian snicker so they'll
take a look
yeah he's got him base is empty for
freddie freeman
out to left field jay bruce back
pedaling and he makes the grab
the inning is over it's a 10 pitch
inning kyle wright gets to start the
grades an important one for him
yeah kyle last time you see three and
third scoreless
75 pitches though we'd like to see him
be able to lengthen out a little bit
hopefully we see a good one
something else we've seen kyle a time or
two two out trouble he's got some here
and didi gregorius is coming up there
two balls two strikes
it's on the ground right to second that
chivari has got it and wright
is through the first inning and the
braves have a runner at first with one
out for ronald acuna
so we get a miss three strikeouts for
arietta
second one of this inning it's always a
big out when you sit him down yes
and a strike three calls four strikeouts
three in the inning dansby swanson
doesn't think so
but that was a beautiful pitch that
sinker is really moving to the outer
edge
all right issues his second walk of the
game
and it comes in front of bryce harper
which is not always a good idea
oskins the man at first the pitch
it's hit to second at javaria two second
for one and the throw to first is in
time
kyle wright gets harper to double up and
we head to the fourth no score in philly
at it just like ozuna whipped with that
one
five strikeouts for arietta five
strikeouts for arietta he looks sharp
full count pitch for darno here it is
swinging a miss six k's
that ball had some wicked movement and
he sets the braves down in order
look at the movement on this pitch darno
no chance as we go to the bottom of the
fourth
jt romuto leads off here in the bottom
of the fourth
in the air to left field that ball is
crushed
and it is gone into the last
row of the section home run number four
he's homered in three straight games
and the phillies take a one-nothing lead
and that was a hanger by right and jt
delivered
segora walks that puts two on on the
corners
for jay bruce in the air to right field
that ball's hit like a missile
and it is gone into the phillies bullpen
a three-run line drive home run by jade
bruce
it's four-nothing phillies duval
flight out to hazley his first time up
swings and lines one droid is tailing
away from harper hill dive and make the
catch
bryce harper lunging to take that one
just off the turf
and deval is robbed of extra bases two
away he caught that thing right on the
edge
yes indeed jake so two outs and
jt real muto steps to the plate
fly ball right center field that one's
well struck
a sinker and that ball is caught by nick
marchakis right
in front of the scoreboard and ronald
acuna jr
three up three down for right first two
hitters have reached
for the braves dangerous hitters up
there in dansby swanson two on nobody
out
that one said shark weed is short
there's one there's two and look at
kangri looking to see if he can get a
triple play
that is a huge double play
out to left center field jay bruce
sprinting toward a spot reaches up and
he makes the catch
and the inning is over better bring up
jay bruce he's got the biggest blow
in this one opposite way
and that lawn dart drops for a hit bruce
on his way to second
and he will get there that's an old
veteran right there tom
i'm getting jammed but i'm going to
fight this one off i guess
almost like oh excuse me there's kingery
who's old for two in the ball game
ripped toward left but duvall is there
great job kyle wright he is through
six innings now the braves bats need to
come to life for him
harper 90 feet away with an insurance
run that'll bring up
dede gregorius and they get an
additional run
d.d gregorius the line drive single to
right field harper scores
five nothing going to the ninth inning
the phillies with a five to nothing lead
here is dansby swanson to lead off swing
at a miss
threw it again and this time had swanson
out front braves down to their
final out the 3-2 pitch twig and a miss
he got him way out in front
and the ball game is over excellent job
by the phillies pitching staff tonight
as the phillies win it five to nothing